the heavy fighting in the east and south
of the country this video shows you
ukrainian soldiers firing rocket
launchers in the direction of russian
forces
in the southern city of mariupol the
ukrainians say russia hit a besieged
steel works with 35 airstrikes in just
24 hours that's a lot of firepower chris
livesay is in ukraine where he has been
talking with people caught up in all of
this violence chris good morning to you
good morning ukraine says russian forces
have captured several villages in the
donbass region now the center of the
invasion but not the only front
as ukraine fiercely fights back in the
east a new front may be appearing to the
country's west for two days mysterious
explosions in transnistria the
pro-kremlin breakaway region of moldova
where russian troops are based moldova
without naming names says the blasts
were aimed at creating pretext for
straining the security situation
this as the global security situation
grows more fragile with russia
repeatedly firing missiles directly over
ukraine's nuclear plants
what is this are they threatening or
correcting fire i'm speechless said
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
accusing russia of threatening to turn
nuclear power into a weapon on the very
anniversary of the chernobyl explosion
that shot a fireball high into ukraine's
sky 36 years ago
amid the threat of russian shelling no
light is allowed save for these candles
to honor the dead in the nearby town of
slovutic built from scratch for the
evacuees
even more traumatic than the worst
nuclear disaster in history is russia's
invasion today says mayor yuri fomicho
when a tank battalion occupied the
chernobyl plant risking yet another
catastrophe before retreating after a
month
even mayor fomachov himself was taken
hostage enraged citizens rose up waving
ukrainian flags
soldiers fired warning shots and stun
grenades but they refused to disperse
until their mayor was freed and their
town liberated survivors now of not one
but two historic tragedies in ukraine
says alexi who witnessed both the
reactor and this war explode
we never expected either of them
chernobyl 36 years ago or russia
attacking its brothers today i can't
wrap my head around it all they can do
is remember those lost in one nuclear
disaster and hope not to bear witness to
another
and now energy nuclear or otherwise is
yet another weapon in this war today
russian energy firm gazprom says it cut
off the gas to poland and bulgaria
because they wouldn't pay in rubles
ukraine says it's the start of quote gas
blackmail aimed at europe tony it's a
worrying development chris livesay in
ukraine chris thank you very much